You remember the first time you came and
we worked out together?
Listen, I'll f***ing.
So that was it.
That was like the heyday.
I'll give you an example. So, Charlie.
Charlie Mac. For those who do not know,
Charlie, Mac used to be Will's
security. And Charlie Mac basically has
been in Will's life forever, Charlie
tells me. This is in, like, the
beginning of my career. Kev, you got to
get the Will. You got to get around,
Will. You know, everybody who knows
Charlie Mac, they know Charlie Mac does
his best.
Kev. Kev, Kev, I'm telling you. I'm
telling you. I'm telling you. You got
to be around, Will. You got to be
around, Will. You just got to show up.
You just got to. I'm just saying. Just
show up. You got to show up. You just
got to be in it. You just got to be.
You just. You got to be.
You got to be. You got to be. You got
to be near that level of greatness.
And if you spend time if you spend time
saying, what the f*** are you laughing
at? I'm I'm trying to help you.
I'm trying to help you. He's filming
because it's so funny. New York.
Charlie calls me Kev.
Will is doing Men in Black.
They're filming it in New York.
You got to get down here.
You got to come to set the director.
Everybody cool? But he just got to get
some of that energy. You got to get his
energy. I'm telling you, shit.
Just going to happen. All right.
I mean. Okay.
Do you want me just to come? Whatever.
I'll figure it out. The first time I
do, we come to New York. That's one of
the first times I see you on set.
Wow. This is where I got to see your
big trailer, right? This two times I
visited you on set.
Oh, man, this is dope as f***.
Look at this trailer.
God damn double decker trailer.
Holy shit. You had a busy day.
So we talked for a second. You were
right back out. Couldn't really do
much. Go visit you on set again.
Will's got a trainer with him now.
Things have changed. He's got a
personal trainer on set.
By the way, this is where I got the
idea to get a personal trainer and have
him travel with me.
Daryl Foster. Daryl.
Daryl Foster is in Will's gym trailer.
Will has a gym trailer.
I got the idea to get a gym trailer
from f***ing Will. You're right.
I need a gym trailer. Right.
Okay. Iron sharpens iron.
This is what I need. This is what the
f*** Will had. I got to get the same
thing. Will.
Unbeknownst to him, his guy's like, Yo,
go in there in a gym trailer.
Will in there he just f***ing around.
We go in the gym trailer.
The trainers in there, he hit the bell.
Bing. What's up, man?
How you doing? Hey, good.
Y'all in or out? I don't understand.
What? You in or out.
You come in here, You in my sanctuary.
You don't f*** around.
Either you came to work or you came to
f***ing do nothing.
You won't do nothing in my house.
I came to see. I came to see Will.
Charlie Mac told me. Come and see, will
you? Doing the set or not?
Yeah, yeah. I'll put it up.
Yeah. I get, I get down, I get one in I
go. Struggling with a set.
Yeah. Okay. We got a bitch in here.
Who the f*** is this?
Who.
Who is he?
I mean, literally, I ended up doing a
f***ing workout.
I ended up doing a workout?
Yes. I just came to tell Will how you
see me after you. Like. Yeah.
Kev, he. He don't f***.
Around. No, no, no.
Derek. Yeah, he was.
He's a I didn't know if you was ever
going to speak to me again after that.
I didn't know what the f*** that was.
I was really. I was upset.
Like, I left. Like I left, you know?
I don't know. I can't beat him.
But in the cars. What the f*** you
think he was talking to?
Call me a bitch because I couldn't do
the goddamn man. He didn't even ask me
how much I can bench.
He just get.
Down. He put it there.
That's a lot of plates. I don't know if
those plates are right for me. I think
that's Will. Them plates are for Will.
They. They not for me.